hi everybody you're going to really love
this interview with a man who's been a
mentor to me
whether he likes it or not uh since i
was a wee lad
and that's uh dr john mather of
national air aeronautics and space
administration
who has been a foundational leader in
the field of the cosmic microwave
background radiation and now
he studies the uh the early universe in
a slightly later garb
via the james webb space telescope which
he is on the lead scientist on
and foremost proponents thereof john of
course won the
nobel prize in 2006 and features
prominently in my book losing the nobel
prize he is
a hero to many of us he's an
old-fashioned experimentalist
and he is an amazing uh spirit in terms
of
all the great things he's contributed
with humility
and uh just just a uh just a tremendous
individual i learned so much from him to
get his answers to the thrilling three
final questions that i've patented and
trademarked and copyrighted and all
those no i didn't do that
but i want you to sign up for my mailing
list at bryankeating.com
and you'll get access to those uh
answers and you won't want to miss them
because his
answers really uh portray a very uh
gentle soul
a kind of zen-like uh character uh who i
got
to know so much better on this interview
and you won't want to miss he
the way that he responds to the
questions that i use to humanize
these ultra brainiacs these laureates
who honor me
by coming on my show as well as all the
guests that do so i have to be honest
with you
so please subscribe to the podcast
wherever you're getting this listening
to this watching this
uh give it a thumbs up and uh and also
subscribe to the mailing list if you
want to get john's answers to the
thrilling
three final questions johnson ninth
nobel prize winner i've had on the show
and he's really one of the best so sit
back enjoy this episode of into the
impossible with dr john mather
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from
magic
and we are talking with uh
john mather who has been a hero of mine
for decades i met him when i was a young
graduate student right after
uh his most uh no notable noteworthy
discoveries in kobe and the fires
instrument
and the real motivation along with a
huge team and i want to talk about
scientific leadership and team building
and all the things that you're known for
that are so hard to learn
much harder than learning about the
cosmic background radiation i think
but john how are you doing today i'm
fine thank you i'm
surviving this coping thing pretty well
uh uh pretty well
set up at the house here i don't have to
go out
we get groceries delivered so we're
taking advantage of modern technology to
protect ourselves
and to travel the world virtually that's
what we're doing all the time
yeah it's certainly if someone had told
me a couple of you know
months before this all started that we'd
all be kind of cooped up and
communicating only via telecon i would
have said welcome to my world
you know because i always thought john
that astronomers like us would
spend our time on telescopes not on
telecons but
unfortunately we seem to spend most of
our time dealing with these
and uh but surprisingly people have made
it through
and uh and i've done it in in uh
in concert to maintain my sanity by
talking to many people on this show on
the into the impossible
podcast and many of them are your fellow
nobel laureates and i want to
send greetings from some of them to you
like ray weiss barry barish
and others who have uh honored me by the
coming on the into the impossible
podcast so
uh this will be on youtube and and
you'll see their videos there as well
i want to start off with um with your
history because i've been
going over some of your your back story
your origin story and i
always think it's it's interesting
people are fascinated with
origins either their own origins their
birthdays
and new years and things like that what
attracted you most about cosmology
since since uh it became your career but
did something
about cosmology and wanting to
understand the universe first lead you
to
to this career or was it merely
something you were good at
it's a much more accidental than that um
when i was a kid i was reading books
about cosmology there was a 123 infiniti
from
george gamoth right and so
i was aware of the expanded universe
story
but i thought well we'll never be able
to figure that out will we
and then in college uh the cosmic
microwave background was discovered
while i was a freshman i think
and so okay well maybe people could
learn a little bit and i'm in graduate
school and i think i want to be like
richard feynman i want to
figure out the secrets of quantum
mechanics and um
people said well by the way um are you
rich
because there are no jobs for radical
physicists right now
okay no i'm not so what else would you
like to do okay i'm beginning to get
tired of studying in the library so i'll
go around and talk to faculty members
see what they're doing
so i talked to a couple and this
project of measuring the cosmic
microwave background was was up
it was just five years after the
discovery oh this is something a
graduate student could make progress on
so i worked with mike warner who you
know well as well
my counterpart on the spitzer space
telescope that's right
anyway uh so we worked together in paul
richard's lab and
we built up some stuff and we measured
some things and
it worked but it wasn't very interesting
so okay well this is pretty hard so uh
then my thesis advisor paul richards uh
went on a sabbatical when he came back
uh from britain with a concept for a
balloon born
instrument that could measure the
spectrum of the cosmic microwave
background radiation and it could do it
a lot
better than we could ever do it on the
ground so okay so i'll work on that
so we worked on that for a while and
finally we got tired of working on it
and fixing it we said well it's time to
go
try it so we took it down to texas to
the balloon base there and we launched
it and it didn't work
oh crap excuse me so now what do we do
well paul let me finish my thesis
describing the non-working
flight hardware and the and the not very
interesting ground-based experiment
and um i was off to new york to get a
job at nasa
so okay well i'll do something else this
is way too hard
so i got to new york i was working for
pat thaddeus
and we were going to do molecular
astronomy with radio telescopes
well of course it turns out that's also
really hard
so okay but after i've been there about
six months nasa said
oh well we have it's now five years
since the moon landing
what are we going to do now we'll ask
the scientists what they want to do
so we got a call for proposals and i
said boss my thesis project failed
we should try it in outer space okay
i'm telling up they call that literally
yeah
so i thought well this isn't gonna work
but we might as well try
so we wrote our little proposal and uh
nothing much happened for a while but it
was clearly interesting to some people
so a couple years later nasa said you
know this is a serious idea
um we're going to start up a study at
nasa goddard space flight center in
greenville maryland where i still
am and so they said here um
let's give you some good engineers to
work with and so
it's not just an idea it's let's figure
it out
let's make this happen so that was 1976
and a lot happened between then and
launch but it did work
so um launch was in 1989 and right away
we got our first results
uh the ones that are famous so um
within a few weeks we had a spectrum of
the cosmic background radiation that was
oh so much better than anything we ever
could have done another way
being in space is good and so i got a
standing ovation when i showed my chart
to the astronomical society
and oh my going i guess this is really
important
myself my perspective had been well my
job is just to get it right
i wasn't even thinking about whether it
was important just got to get it right
so i was really pleased but a little
surprised by all that enthusiasm
because i thought doesn't everybody know
that's the right answer
no we don't of course right that's why
we call it
uh science right that's that's how it
got started
and a couple of years later uh another
instrument team on our
on our mission made the front pages with
the map of the cosmic background
radiation with the hot and cold spots
everywhere
and that was the first clear discovery
of that
and so suddenly now we have a
measurement of the initial conditions of
the universe
the spatial structure and the
temperature so
okay you ought to be able to figure out
everything if you know that
well not quite but you should try at any
rate
so um i was stunned by that one in a
different way
i thought well this is way too complex
my theoretical friends are never going
to figure this one out
but actually they did pretty quickly
they settled on the equations that
should describe this process
and they were able to make a very good
model that explained everything we saw
and then when we got more data from more
experiments and
two more satellites after that it all
fit
beautifully up until very recently
[Music]
when as everybody knows we're having a
problem again that we got
two different measurements of the hubble
constant and they're significantly
different
so i don't know where that one's going
to go but whoever said nature was simple
you know so many things to unpack that
you said that really harken back to
lessons that i've learned and try to
teach to my students channeling your
advisor
paul richards who is of course a friend
and a colleague on the polar bear and
simon's array
projects uh co-led out of uh uc berkeley
your alma mater with uh by adrian lee
who's one of my oldest friends and
and we've been working in this field for
20 years plus
and uh some things that as you're
talking i'm just wondering like
you and i share a little bit of the dna
of paul richards in that
i'm sure you say things you know every
so often
that come directly from him such as when
he
you know would just stand up during a
talk and say you're not telling
a fiction story you're telling a
scientific story so
do you have any um any anecdotes from
paul that you
that are rated g for my audience you
know the the one story that
had the most emotion for it was that
paul went off on a trip to japan
and he put his viewgrass in his checked
luggage
and they did not arrive so oh my gosh
what do we do now
so he told his story about how he
finally got him it was just
within minutes of the talk he was
supposed to give
and then uh so that i remembered never
put your view graphs in your checked
luggage
now we don't even use few graphs anymore
but at any rate that was then and
uh another thing that he said that still
sticks with me is uh
in your talks that people can't absorb
everything you're going to say so
remember the three things you really
want people to understand
and make sure they get that part yeah i
think that's fantastic and actually
i've kind of taken that advice that you
just said to heart with my
podcast and interviews that i get to do
and i'm so blessed to be able to do
uh because it's true people might
remember they say people remember
one or two percent of a book that they
read we'll talk about the very first
light which i remember all of of course
but they say you can't really remember
it so part of my selfish motivation in
doing these podcasts and
conversations on clubhouse and elsewhere
is that
uh i get to remember maybe three percent
to five percent because i have to
really read take notes prepare and one
thing that really shines through in
in uh in the reading that i've done with
about you and your book etc
is the influence of mentors and the
influence of
of them on your career and even on your
style as a scientist and just now
talking about paul richards
it reminds me of a story that you uh
told in your nobel uh biography
about how your father had had an
influence in your mother too
on on the direction taking you into a
scientific career
uh and you talk about your father who
had a laboratory with liquid nitrogen
and calorimeters he was at the
university of
wisconsin uh i believe it was madison
was that right
well that was for his doctorate but he
when i was a kid he was at rutgers
university oh right
yeah and we were living on a research
farm way up in the
far north country in new jersey and he
became expert
in uh in in this optimization process to
produce more protein i suppose and more
and better milk
yeah and that's a vital importance to
you know it's the number one export of
wisconsin as we all know but then
of course for the whole country but i
wonder what was his influence on you and
as a scientist it's inescapable for me
just for those that may not know
a lot of what john has done in his world
was using types of calorimeters called
volometers that measure
ancient heat not you know ancient milk
protein or new
milk protein but can you tell us about
the influence of your father
and other scientific mentors that you
had ranging from paul richards and
richard well i'd say
the most direct influence people have
had on me is
similar to what people said about david
wilkinson
he said people said that he said
get students give them really hard
problems maybe impossible problems don't
tell them that they're impossible
and and let them figure them out yeah
and so
uh i have taken on really hard problems
and uh they've gradually yielded bit by
bit
uh so that we could actually build the
kobe satellite and now
even the james webb space telescope so
our whole community
has been doing this bit by bit we've
been inching forward to make better
equipment
to make measurements that would have
been completely imaginary
when i was a youngster nobody could have
ever dreamed you could measure that
yeah the precision the phenomenal
precision of course john you're
you're most famous and this iconic image
that you know i think about almost every
day when you when you
you know displayed those view graphs
back then or what have you with
showing the black body spectrum of the
cosmic microwave background
with these tiny little boxes i'm like
why didn't you take off the boxes yeah i
was just a kid back then
but but it was in reality it was the
error bars the
expression of the uncertainty that we
all have to
account for as scientists because we can
never do a perfect measurement
but in some sense this measurement or
maybe the cosmos in a sense
uh because those error bars you had to
magnify them 400 times just to get them
to be
visible on a view graph but i wonder
when i saw that i remember hearing that
it was the most perfect black body
that was imaginable and i remember
thinking well how do they know that it's
the most perfect black body
how do you compare to a standard black
body to say
i've done better than a block so black
body maybe you can recapitulate john
would be a delight for me to hear
what is a black body and how do you know
that that was the best black body ever
measured if it's the best black body
ever measured
yeah so okay just uh one small factual
um modification first graph that we
showed
had a precision of maybe a percent
it took uh quite a long time for dale
fixon my colleague to
run the software that would uh get rid
of every error that we could get rid of
and so that's what it took to get
parts 50 parts per million so that was a
huge accomplishment on his part
so what about the design that made this
possible
well number one is a differential
instrument so we say okay
we'll have a black body and we'll put it
in and out of the antenna
and see if anything changes how
different is the sky from
the ideal thing that we flew and so then
you have to design that black body so
it's really black
and then you have to argue that it is
not reflecting anything
else but itself and so we designed with
that in mind and we tried to test for it
so we believed that it was and we argued
that it was
um and so you actually didn't
need to measure the reflectance of this
thing the reflectance
is one minus the emissivity so you we
measured and uh david wilkinson did it
in the lab
actually uh it's about a partner in a
million
so that's astonishing you can do that uh
if you have complete control of the
shape and the temperature and the
environment
and so those controls allowed uh humans
really to establish that the
that the microwaves that we were
perceiving in all directions were indeed
of a thermal character uh and i had on
recently
john um i had on giant narlacar uh who
i've known personally for 20 years
almost and he used to visit my colleague
my late great colleague jeffrey burbidge
who is here at uc san diego
who worked alongside giant with fred
hoyle
in the maintenance of the view even
after kobe
even after kobe fire us and dmr
he maintained the modified version of a
steady state theory which
came to be called the uh squasi steady
state universe
i wonder what did you make of all that
after not only making this discovery
uh but even going on as you say onto
even bigger better or not bigger or
better but just different projects
that being so settled in your mind that
it was a black body
i mean fred was no dummy he was a
brilliant man so is giant
they still believe in the giant does
unfortunately fred and jeff are no
longer with us
the giant still believes in a version of
the steady state model being competi
you know competitive or at least
believable
plausible in some sense what do you say
to to people like that that are so
bright
uh but have this view that certainly is
is heterodoxical
wow well i usually don't think it's
worth arguing
um because people that have made up
their mind have their own reasons
um it would be interesting to ask well
why do you still believe
this when we have this other evidence
but i haven't
have not made that question so
the looking at it from the outside we
say well how can you possibly imagine
that your story
produces this degree of perfection of
the spectrum
and so um as far as i know they can't do
it
but i guess they think they can well
yeah they were very creative
um in terms of evading the different
constraints even
after pansies and wilson and even after
uh the discoveries that you and paul
made early even before kobe
and david wilkinson who is my grand
advisor my
phd advisors advisor a titan of
cosmology and astronomy
uh for whom the wmap satellite gets its
w
and uh rightfully so but uh they would
come up with all sorts of other ideas
like there was thermalization there was
dust and unfortunately i happened to
know a lot about dust as you know
uh from uh from it uh playing a big role
in the
in the lack of a nobel prize perhaps for
at least
maybe not me but but for other people on
my team and if not me
but uh but this thermalization of uh by
dust and
this creation field that they claim and
you know it's it's it's a cute thing but
uh but they claim that this creation
field which is what made the
uh quasi-steady state quasi uh created a
certain amount of molecules of hydrogen
every year and that
uh that is actually you know one of the
underpinnings
that was backed up by the discovery of
dark energy so not only can they explain
the
the cmb and its black body character but
also
the uh the accelerated expansion of the
universe
so um now i'm not agreeing with it i'm
just pointing out sociologically it's
very hard
uh for uh for what they say an ugly fact
to kill a beautiful theory even in even
in
dickie peeble's role in wilkinson that
model
that they talk about you know this
extremely well is right before you were
in school
but um they never mentioned the big bang
once in the companion paper to pension
wilson
they talk about a cyclic universe or the
the collapse of a previous cycle or
something like that so it's just
it's it's interesting what do you think
it would take for i mean do you think we
can ever have unanimity in science do
you think that's a good thing or a bad
thing that we
you know to to achieve unity but maybe
we can't have it
well i don't know that it's a an
objective that we should seek
um and i think nothing would make people
happier than to discover that we've all
been wrong about something
and we've all got something to do and
we've made an advance of some sort
so i don't think we're stuck in some
kind of group think the way some of my
other colleagues think i think we are
very busy pursuing
the possibility that we're all wrong um
so it's
um but each scientist has to make a some
judgment well where is the payoff likely
to be
so uh if you're looking where it's
pretty unlikely uh that you're going to
find a discovery then um
well after a while you might get tired
yeah i've been doing a few conversations
on the podcast with people
surrounding theories of everything and
and whether or not such a
quest is motivated by a desire to seek
unification
or beauty symmetry simplicity
and i'm reminded as one of your heroes
richard feynman used to say
science is the belief in the ignorance
of experts
meaning that if if einstein just trusted
newton we would never heard of general
relativity and
it's a good thing to be suspicious i
don't know of a scientist that says
oh well fred hoyle said it he's an
eminent scientist he discovered the oil
resonance and
stellar nucleosynthesis so i'm just
going to believe him about the steady
state
yeah yeah no that's not us we don't do
that
but yeah the general public might think
that we're all
proof thinkers because we all say the
same thing but that's because the
evidence is pretty strong
yes and i think you know there is this
notion in in um
in the context of perception by the
public of science as
um you know kind of this all-powerful
thing as as you i might have mentioned
we have this arthur c clarke center for
human imagination at uc san diego and
this podcast is part of that center i'm
the co-director of it
and arthur c clarke used to say famously
we open the podcast
every every episode this one will have
it too and we open it with his word
saying any sufficiently advanced
technology
is indistinguishable from magic and i
love that quote
but it also connotes that yeah we're
doing magic and you know you don't ask a
magician how he or she does his or her
tricks right
you just trust that they know what
they're doing but uh but it's
interesting to see
uh i always wondered because you know
you have
okay so we know in hindsight that this
discovery is born out but there's you
know i get emails every day you know
mather was wrong you know the big bang
never happened
how do you because i see you as this
happy very slender and fit buddha you
know that
nothing you're kind of impervious to us
attacks and assaults and
and you have this just gravitas and
you've always had i think when you're a
baby you had gravitas i don't know
correct me if i'm wrong but i don't
remember
take notes we'll ask uh i'll ask
you know the historians out there to do
some research but um
but john how do you weather you know the
attacks because
until something is confirmed in science
and consensus can be built up
it's an anxious thing right i mean i
heard from uh barry barish and ray weiss
uh that they were kind of nervous after
the initial discovery of
of the in spiral of these black holes
until
there was a second event on boxing day
in december of 2015 and then they were
like this is
forget it was slam dunk and then they
decided you know let's go full ahead
how did you handle i mean it's hard as
you said to go into space
so how do you how did you view it i mean
did you view it something that we needed
to confirm
i recall dmr was only the differential
microwave radiometer
if it had been a factor of two less
sensitive maybe it wouldn't have been a
discovery so
how do you handle the attacks as a
scientist in a way that my audience can
kind of learn from how to stand true to
what you believe
okay well the um lots of different jobs
in science
my job as i looked at it was build some
equipment and go measure something
and uh and the interpretation is some
other person's job
so when i say this is what we found i
think it's
i think it's right we've done the best
we can we've got a big team of
scientists we all
looked backwards and forwards all over
everything we couldn't find anything
wrong that we did
and we haven't thought of anything wrong
that um
anybody else did and we haven't even
thought of a way that the universe
could fool us so this is the best we can
do here it is
so that's our job and then uh plenty of
other people say well no that can't be
right i better does it
so a little story there when we
showed our spectrum at the astronomical
society and we got the standing ovation
somebody heard jeff burbidge who was
chairing the session
to say they've swallowed it hook line
and sinker
so okay so now people certainly have
strong opinions about the interpretation
uh but there was no question in our
minds that we had confirmed that black
body curve
and we were a lot more cautious about
the hot and cold spots
um because uh we knew how hard that was
and there were lots of ways that
we couldn't be making mistakes or that
the instrument could be fooling us
or that the nearby universe could be
fooling us dust clouds just as you said
they could all be in their way and
magnetic fields around the earth were
bothering
the equipment so we had to fool with all
that stuff and
try to imagine how we could be fooled
and so
um it was about six or eight months
between the day when ned wright showed
the science team that here are the spots
and the time that we agreed that it was
ready to show the world
so by the way ned was the person who
knew the first he was the very first one
to know
yes i i gave a talk at ucla a year or
two ago and reconnected with ned
ned was actually the editor uh for my
first app j
article in the late 90s as a first
author
and he sent back the first draft this is
you know on pine you know emacs or what
he said back like i don't do mime
okay i don't know what that means but i
guess i attached
you know some file as an attachment you
know says pre-pdf basically
he's very purse uh you know as they used
to say about your fellow nobel laureate
iraq
he never uses two words when none will
do
but uh but and that is a phenomenal
influence on
many of us in this field and and you
point out in your book and elsewhere
you say kobe was a team effort our team
gave their complete concentration and
support for a very
long time they dealt with having to
redesign the mission after the
challenger explosion
they tested the observatory extensively
and they fixed the problems that they
found
the analysis team found ways to
compensate for systematic errors are
built into the designs
and the end got the measurements far
beyond the require the formal
requirements for sensitivity and
accuracy
this to me brings up two points one is
the importance of a team
and leadership in science and the other
one is dealing with setbacks such as the
things that are out of your control
the challenger explosion a covid
pandemic um
let's talk about that first of all team
how did you hire how do you hire people
as a as a scientist on lead scientists
on jwst
how do you think about it as a team
first and foremost
after all i don't maybe i'm wrong but i
never got any
i know i'm not wrong about myself but i
never got any training on how to manage
a team
did you get some special training on how
to manage and build a team and inculcate
the values that your team has or
how can we learn from from these
practices well i wish i could tell you
um when i got to uh goddard space flight
center here in greenville i was only
30 years old i said i do not know how to
do any of this
i'm going to go to my meetings with my
fellow scientists and engineers and
we'll work together on this
but i'm you know i'm not the person to
manage this project
um don't even ask me i have no idea how
to do that
so um i got her to sign
professionals uh professional scientists
professional engineers who are my
supervisors and my mentors
and and the engineers really did the
hard job of figuring out how to make
this thing work
they far outnumbered the scientists so
we were able to
join an existing engineering
organization that already had
basically all the talent that was needed
um
when i came to goddard there was a
project we were just finishing up called
the iue
the international ultraviolet explorer
and
it was launched soon after i got there
and um
so the team still was intact so okay
let them take over this new idea and let
them figure out how to
build something and they'll do what
those scientists want to do
and uh and they were brilliant uh very
wonderful people i still am in touch
with a few of the originals
and so um basically they knew how to do
the stuff that people think
i did and then yeah sharing the credit
and then um
making the team resilient enough to
overcome obstacles that are
out of your control after the challenger
blew up i mean that's one of my earliest
memories as a kid
in ninth grade you know being brought to
some auditorium and seeing uh you know
about to watch the launch of this
teacher going into space
and then the tragic awful images uh that
resulted
uh from that but um and you were at nasa
and so
how did uh how do you overcome those
those kinds of challenges that none of
us can put you know we all make these
risk registers you know that document
well this is a probability of the euro
is going to fluctuate against the dollar
and then in chile is going to have a
peso and then that's going to be cause
concrete locally
anyway we have all these matrices and we
have to
but they never have in them you know
explosion of a vehicle or i mean maybe
in nasa they do but but not in
what we do and yeah so how do you deal
with those those really unknown unknowns
as a
fellow washington used to say i don't
think there's a big plan you deal with
them when you
when they arrive so um
we were very fortunate some of our
managers said
we'll find a way they didn't know what
it was going to be but
we'll find a way we didn't get this far
to give up that's how everybody felt
so um there were a few people who said
well actually the shuttle that we were
going to launch the web
sorry the kobe on just wasn't really
that good in the first place
so let's get a different rocket find a
delta rocket or something
so our deputy project manager said i'll
find one
and he did
it was quite a significant
accomplishment to find one when they
weren't available
but he found one and so as it turned out
it had to be assembled from parts that
had been lying around
because it was not actually a whole
rocket available
but people knew that the project we were
building was important enough to be
worth
trying to rescue and um
wouldn't it take too long before people
people realized
actually if we could solve this problem
the kobe satellite could be the first
thing that we launched for science
after the challenger right and it was so
when
even before the space shuttle took the
hubble telescope into space
so um we went from being well okay
do it if you can here this is a sort of
best efforts project um
we know this is really hard to suddenly
you're the you're the one you have to
get this right right now
hurry and so that actually cleared a lot
of obstacles
and uh basically you don't have to argue
with people to tell
someone something's important when
everybody can see it and feel it
so everyone knew
actually uh although i didn't quite
believe it people started saying right
at the beginning
there's a nobel prize in here and i
thought
well there is or there isn't it's not us
to say we have to do a good job
that's right so um so well
we try to do a good job so i think that
uh
feeling uh went all the way from the
working level
all the way up through top management at
headquarters and
i suppose maybe even in congress some
people knew that that was important
and when you're looking when i look at
nasa today i see
um i see that it has a very strong brand
it's not to say that it hasn't failed i
had on astronaut scott parazynski
just a reminder people listening on
clubhouse we
have many of you in the chat room
hopefully we'll take some questions
for dr mather in just a bit uh but uh i
produce videos with
you know as i say billionaires and
brainiacs and everyone in between
uh which includes me because i'm neither
a billionaire nor brainiac
but we but i had on astronaut uh scott
parazynski
who is an amazing individual spacewalked
seven times
five times on the shuttle uh attempted
to reach mount everest once
and uh failed miserably and then he came
back and did it again and and he and i
were talking and i talked with jessica
maier
uh who's an alumna of uc san diego
scripps institution of oceanography
i talked to her while she was on the
space station which i pointed out was
only 200 miles away it's not that big a
deal
but uh and i've talked to two other
astronauts um
and and i always say nasa's got probably
the strongest brand
in the world you know i have clothes
that say nasa my kids have clothes that
say nasa on it how does it feel to work
in an organization like nasa for
basically your whole adult life
oh well to me it's just going to work
and work on the coolest thing there is
to work on now
so we don't usually think about how
special that is we just you know have
our job to do
we got to make this thing work whatever
it is that we're working on this week
we got to make it work because you know
we're part of a team and if it doesn't
work
uh all kinds of bad things can happen
not only won't you get the answer that
you wanted but your whole team will be
embarrassed
your support from the congress and so
forth might
dry up you might just end up wrecking
things badly so
we all take it very very seriously and
uh so nobody wants to be that person who
dropped the ball right the people that i
work with are extraordinary about
keeping track not letting anything get
away from us
talk about now your your desires and
your
um and your uh exposure to to teaching
to communicating discoveries not just by
yourself but you're always so
you know gracious and generous to make
sure that you always tell
science is a team effort uh talk about
your book the very first light which
which changed the way i thought about my
career
when it uh when it first came out and uh
and
wanting to you know kind of channel some
of this infectious
passion and curiosity that you have but
also being cognizant of the politics and
the
and sometimes competition and and uh you
know no nobel prize winner except for
one and i'll ask you this later when i
ask
the question i ask all the nobel
laureates who honor me by coming on my
show
about the imposter syndrome we'll get to
that later but uh but basically all of
them said like
you gotta be crazy like no one ever
thinks about winning a nobel prize but
a lot of other scientists do think about
winning a nobel prize i talk about in my
book losing the nobel prize
when i came here i was told by the
chairman who was the son of
uh is the son of nikolai bassoff who
co-discovered the laser
uh along with your former professor
charlie townes
and uh and this this discovery you know
he basically told me when i was hired
well you're working in a field and we
expect you to to win a nobel prize
basically and this is a man whose father
won the nobel prize
um talk about how when you when you
do your writing and outreach to the
public how do you kind of balance this
this thought in the popular imagination
that science is about credit
is about egos tense politics as well as
the cutting edge science and engineering
that we have to do
how do you balance that and why is it
important to communicate that to the
public
oh my goodness well it's a large and
difficult subject
my perspective is we're in this together
even if we're competitors if you're
working on a project and i'm working on
a project that's supposed to measure the
same thing
and we don't get the same answer that's
really important
so our job is to
get evidence not to win
so if we can get evidence then then
that's a win
so um and we don't know what the
evidence is
so i think a good scientist is always
saying i'm going to get more evidence
i'm not trying to browbeat anybody into
believing me i'm just going to get more
evidence
and so if you're in my world where we
the job is to go measure things then
we're always thinking
how to make a better instrument that can
measure better
so that's you know always in the back of
my mind how would can we measure
something better
um and then of course if you have an
idea then your job next
is to say persuade someone to support
you so you can do this
so then i have to sort of spin a story
about
what you could discover if you could
build it
so then you always have to remember well
it may not be that way
so so i never worried very much about
credit
i thought to tell the truth the only way
to get credit is to give credit
uh if you think you can capture credit
by claiming you did something
um well that'll last for a week and
afterwards people will remember you that
you're the one who took their credit
away from them
and that's not a good thing to do so the
truth uh
is we're all in this together even if it
doesn't feel like it
that's beautiful way to say it john um
talk
just the last bit about about
competition maybe the public
i've noticed a proliferation and and you
were a part of it i was tangentially a
part of it
in a relatively new phenomenon which is
the um
the explication of scientific findings
to the public via press conference
and and the various ways that takes
place recently
we've heard many big discoveries ranging
from possible
evidence for life or byproducts of life
on the planet venus
we've heard you know tales of
extraterrestrial technology
you know potentially visiting the earth
we've heard obviously the
the discoveries of my experiment bicep2
etc where you know these were these were
held press conferences
and and it's true that these discoveries
you know if confirmed
are are quite amazing and astounding but
the question of the obligation of
scientists to not only have
you know publicize the results because
taxpayers pay our salaries
but also to correct any misapprehensions
that what we claimed once on the front
page of the new york times
maybe that didn't turn out to be so so i
wonder with your experience your long
career
what do you think about press
conferences and are they a net benefit
for science or not
a good question um depends on motivation
doesn't it a little bit
uh if your motivation giving a press
conference is to explain something
that you're very sure of uh that people
will want to know that's one thing if
your motivation is to be first and to
claim credit
then you're often pretty likely to be in
trouble
because it's not mature so a standard
policy for me
and most of the people that i work with
is no press conferences until your
manuscript is selected for publication
so we just don't want we don't want to
get in trouble
and people do um so
uh it's so easy to be eager to tell the
people and to tell them
say how cool this thing is and it's also
so easy to be wrong
it happens so often um and who knows
whether your current excitement is
right or wrong
yeah when i think about these these
press conferences sometimes i say
you know we should have we don't have a
very big pr budget as it is but
maybe we should you know keep half of it
in in uh reserve
to hedge against the fact that we may
need to have
a uh a uh if not a retraction an
explanation
uh or a uh an update to the to the
claims that were made
uh so we have some questions on uh on
clubhouse i'm gonna take one or two
right now so these are
listeners uh john that that tune into
the show
i'm gonna take harvine first harvine
welcome
you're talking with none other than john
mather uh who is a titan of the field of
astronomy
cosmology and other experimental
astrophysical endeavors
harvey go ahead i'll see if make sure
john can hear you hello
hello thank you so much um dr martha
my question really related to the
funding of science
because in in your career through the
span of your career
you you i mean it's covered the
period from just a few years after the
moon landing
all the way to to to these years
where it seems that it's so difficult to
get consensus
on facts and science how do you think
we can continue to
shape a consensus that it's important
for governments to allocate
budget to science especially when there
seem to be so many other
competing priorities i'd like people to
know
uh that there are practical benefits for
the science that we do along with the
intellectual and emotional benefits that
we get
so um i like to share both so
in in my quest to understand the early
universe my
basic wish is how did i get here i want
to know
what are all the steps from the big bang
to now as near as you can tell
so there are an awful lot of them and so
a lot of the most complicated ones are
biology and geology
so i can't work on them i don't know
anything about them but i can cheer when
those people do
then it turns out of course those are
really practically important for our own
future
since we're busy changing the planet
that we live on as fast as we can go
so there's a huge practical importance
of of basic science um
uh bill gates is now telling everybody
as he's been saying for quite a long
time
if you don't figure out energy supply
and get to zero carbon
we're cooked that wasn't his word but
we're cooked
uh so um we can't uh get there with just
uh
um be more economical about your
food and your in your driving you have
to actually solve a big engineering
problem
and right now it's not solved so
from a very practical sense we have to
work on that
if we want to be here in a thousand
years we got to solve that one and the
only path
that he chose us is science and
engineering
you can't really expect the public to
to do what it takes unless somebody's
given them the tools
i can't buy an electric car if there is
not very good okay we have
another question let's go to eric
uh and then we'll go to arthur and then
we'll
continue some questions i have so eric
you are now a
speaker what do you have to say to dr
john mather hi doctor um i had a
question
for you in from the perspective of like
i'm a
entrepreneur working in biotech and i
was curious if you could comment on how
funding has changed over the course of
your career
uh when dealing with uh company like
private company partnerships with
government
so universities finding industry
partners and how that kind of
perhaps has changed or where you see
that there's problems or
areas that we could we could address so
i have a vested interest in that
and i'm also curious to see like
effective strategies like you know
there's been a lot of demand for
coronavirus research
and everyone pushed for it but now
people are kind of becoming complacent
so
okay well i don't actually have
information to properly answer your
question
i would say uh over my lifetime there
have been huge changes though
um when i was young for instance the
military supported
basic science and then congress said no
we don't want you to do that anymore
that should be handled uh by uh
civilians
so we that's that's a big change
so i think you have better information
than i do about your question
okay fair enough thank you thank you uh
arthur
uh she or she uh is the next one with
his hand raised arthur you're on with dr
john mather
you mentioned earlier that einstein
never doubted newton he would never have
like
you know developed his equations of
relativity and all that
i'm curious what your opinion is of the
current education system where there is
only one right answer and what your
ideal education system would be
to answer is anything about the current
education system i would have to imagine
it
and i have not been a student for all
these many years
so honestly i can't tell you um
so i am i can tell you though that i'm
astonished at how bright the young
people are that are coming into our labs
uh there is no question in my mind that
they're smarter than i am
and they're quicker than i am and they
know stuff i could never know
and they are masters of tools that i
don't know so
at least in the scientists we are doing
a brilliant job
i certainly uh however read the news and
i find out that uh
most people do not receive the civic
education that i got beginning in fourth
grade
so most people are not shown how the
government works
so if they don't know how it works they
try all kinds of weird things
yeah that is a danger um so
uh let me turn now to your next project
which is jwst
and this is a this is a very interesting
project uh for many reasons
one of which is that it may you know
reveal some of the most
interesting and curious aspects of the
universe as well as
aspects of cosmology so can you talk
about your role in jwst
and um and then what its status is uh if
that's not too controversial we talked
about civics for a second so yeah
uh it could be controversial to talk
about its status but please yeah what is
the mission of wjwst
and um what is where does it stand
currently okay well the james
jwst is the james webb space telescope
james webb was the second administrator
of nasa
he's the man who went up to john kennedy
and said here's the plan for apollo
and then he made it happen so about
eight years after
he said here's the plan we actually
landed on the moon so
that to me is a miracle he knew what he
was up to
and he knew how hard the job was so
this is a reminder by the way to anyone
who's planning a great
leap forward don't believe everything
people tell you about
how much it's going to cost there's a
story that you realize you didn't know
and he doubled the budget in the taxi
cab on the way to see the president
and then it was enough but if he had not
done that it would have been a major
national embarrassment
so just remember that scientists and
engineers are optimists
and we no matter how hard we try we
cannot think of all the
bad things that are going to happen to
us and that's probably good or we
wouldn't not maybe
even start so anyway that's who james
webb was
the telescope is a successor for hubble
it is much bigger and much more powerful
the mirror is six and a half meters
across as compared to 2.4 for hubble
and the telescope is cooled down to a
low temperature
so that it can pick up infrared light so
you and i
are transmitting 100 watts of or
maybe more several hundred watts of
infrared power
and so if the telescope is warm it can't
see infrared
so we have made a design which is bigger
and more powerful and cold
which implies all kinds of terrible
engineering difficulties
but they're mostly solved so the status
is
it is as far as we know it is has
been through its final vibration test at
the company that's putting it together
for the final steps in california that's
north of roman space systems
um we are about to button it up and say
it's ready to go in the box so
that'll take about six months but
because we have to be very carefully
going through every single detail so
it's coming
and as far as we know it will meet all
of its requirements
nothing has gone wrong about does it
work the way we think
so i'm feeling very fortunate about that
because
stuff happens and we've escaped all the
major hazards
sometimes after a huge effort but
we have managed to deal with them all
and so
if we are fortunate we'll be shipping
the telescope to the
launch site in french guiana in august
sometime and then uh launching it in uh
the end of
october so coming soon it's not so far
off now
no and can you tell us about the mission
of it is it just a super hubble
telescope it sounds like it's going to
be very different from the hubble
telescope
it's it's it's super and it's different
um
so uh for instance this picture that i'm
showing you behind my head here
is a picture taken with the hubble and
it shows that
if you point your telescope at a more or
less empty place in the sky it will be
filled with galaxies
when people took that picture they were
astonished to see how many galaxies
there are there
and to see that even the hubble was not
going to be able to see far enough to
answer our big question
the big question was well how did the
galaxies get formed
and when and the upshot was the hubble
telescope was not powerful enough to
answer that question
so they said build us another one that
can see wonker wavelengths
so that we can see the redshifted
distant galaxies
and is bigger and more sensitive and so
that tells us to build this
terribly difficult telescope we are
putting up it has several other things
to do
we are going to look for how do the
black holes holes form and grow every
galaxy there seems to have a black hole
in the middle
how did that happen when did that happen
we're going to be looking at stars being
formed inside their dust clouds close up
here right nearby even an orion nebula
for instance the
beautiful dusty glowing clouds of gas
are forming stars as we speak and uh
darn you can't see inside the
interesting stuff is happening where you
cannot see it
because dust is opaque but uh
as it happens nature says well if you
use a longer wavelength you can see
through the dust
so the web telescope has the longer
wavelengths that we can see inside those
dust clouds to see stars being born
so that's another piece of our history
that we want to know about
then the thing we didn't know we would
be able to tackle would be how about all
those planets
now we know now that most stars have
planets and most stars have little ones
at about the right temperature to be
like earth
so um let's go look
so i think we're going to get some
surprises
and i don't know what they are if i knew
that i would be trying to plan to
make an observing program to get them
but
i think somebody's gonna find something
very surprising
yes every time we open a window and
especially one
from such a high perch the highest
frontier uh
we are almost guaranteed a little bit
guaranteed of
extremely interesting but also maybe
serendipitous results that we didn't
expect it's
it's kind of interesting thinking going
back to kobe as we close out
you know people suspected the cmb was a
black body but but there were
alternatives and as i mentioned earlier
there were alternatives that persisted
even
uh you know here in san diego for many
decades even after uh or decades after
the discovery of the cmb but but even a
decade or two after
the discovery uh made by kobe and virus
and dmr
but you know thinking back yeah how
tenuous things are
when you set out to do something and all
the pitfalls and all the challenges that
can come about
along the way and i wonder you know at
certain times maybe this is the right
time to ask you the question i've asked
the
other eight nobel laureates who've come
on the show about half theorists half
experiments
um observers and i want to ask you
this question that comes up a lot in
academia we're we're always judged we're
always graded you know an undergraduate
even in graduate school
then you have to get a prestigious
postdoc then you have to fight it out
uh really to get one of the few uh
faculty positions in this field i mean
there are more people that have won the
nobel prize
uh in uh and let me say there are more
people on the space station right now
that have won the nobel prize in
cosmology and physics that are alive
today shall we say uh including you
thankfully
and the question i have for you is do
you ever along the way
do you ever deal with the imposter
syndrome do you ever feel like
or did you ever feel like rather you
weren't
you know good enough to do whatever it
is that you were being commissioned to
do
did you ever wrestle with that effect
that academics face called the imposter
syndrome
well i never actually called it the
imposter syndrome
but um i think the life of the scientist
is
uh similar to my life which is every day
i get up and work on something which i
can't figure out yet
so every day i'm the imposter who
doesn't know the answer
and so now what am i going to do i don't
have any choice this is my job
i'm going to have to work on the thing
that i haven't figured out yet
and so once in a while i say well
there's somebody over there that's
really smart
what do i do um ask that person for help
is usually the best plan
don't try to beat them try to join them
so it took all of the members of our
kobe science team to do
what we did and and it takes all of the
members of our gigantic
engineering and technical science team
for the web telescope
there are thousands of us and and the
telescope could not go
if we didn't have them
that's right absolutely it's a team
effort you know i always say
science is an infinite game and it's not
like a zero-sum game it's not like chess
where there's winners and losers we can
all win
in an infinite game uh the problem is
nature has an infinite array of armed
forces against us and uh she wages very
cunningly and crafting craftingly
against us
um it's funny because yeah people have
told me uh like barry barish when he
uh i asked him that question did you
ever have the
impostor syndrome and goes what are you
talking about i still have it i said
what do you mean
and he said well when i went up to get
my nobel prize
in stockholm after getting the medal and
they make you sign this book
you can confirm this and it has like all
the laureates
names in it throughout history uh at
least you know for the last hundred
years
and he said he saw einstein's name and
his signature and feynman's name and his
signature
and jaraq and salam and and whoever else
and curry and maria mayer
he said i'm not worthy and uh he said he
still felt that
and i said if he can feel it you know so
can i
yeah well i feel that too i did feel
that when i visited that
and looked at the list my name is on
that same list with
but those guys yeah well they were
geniuses they were brilliant
how did they ever do those things that
they did
and i don't know how they did but they
did them so they had the ability
all of those people to look at nature in
a sort of perpendicular way
which was so different from anybody
else's point of view
say thinking about dirac and his wave
equation for electrons
whoever would have dreamed outside of
him that
you needed to write little matrices that
uh don't commute with each other so
oh my gosh how did you think of that one
and and how did he trust it enough to
find a solution
that said there should be positions oh
man
so there's a lot of uh incredible
imagination out there and a lot of it
turns out to be wrong but that's
why we have lots of people that's right
yeah and the diversity of
viewpoints and vantage contributes to a
healthy vibrant field that i think is
the healthiest field
of endeavor of human beings i'm not
saying it's the best i'm just saying i
get to work with you getting to work
with people i work with people from
antarctica
to uh to northern sweden and and from
saudi arabia
to california it's it's the most
thrilling thing to get their
viewpoints and and talking to people
especially on this app called clubhouse
what's interesting is that people can be
listening all around the world
uh all over the planet of of every
religious faith of every gender
everything and just hearing from them
and hearing
the one thing that unites us all is that
we aren't artificial intelligent robots
you know that have no emotions we're
human beings and
and and science is a human endeavor
despite the stereotypes to the contrary
that we're all just robots
and so forth and john i want to thank
you so much uh we don't know each other
really well but
you should know you've been a huge
influence on my career uh i don't blame
you for any of my mistakes by the way
uh and nobody should but uh but john has
been uh really a remote mentor to me and
now with the benefit of technology such
as this
we can sort of be close together i hope
i can see you again soon
uh when things are well in the world i
wish you all the best i know you're
super busy
thank you for being so gracious with
your time have a great rest of your day
john
thank you brian it's been a pleasure
talking with you and and your listeners
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
[Music]
you